genau das erwarten die roten sind
gemeinde fragen die grünen sind harmlose
frage kannst selber aussuchen welche
fragen auswählen möchte so ganz alle
beantworten ein paar und so weiter
berater ich fange einfach mal an und da
gucke ich mir dabei geht und ob ich
weitermachen möchte
ich greife hier mal rein und da ist auch
schon eine grüne das vielleicht will ihn
anscheinend stadt direkt auf die idee
ist am leichtesten zu öffnen dass sie
einfach abgelöst
beim nächsten mal kann ich schon selber
kaliber 69 und die gilt als produzent
geht deine gespaltene persönlichkeit
auch über die musik hinaus
ich würde sagen ich bin ich habe viele
gesichter
jeder der vielleicht schauspieler ist
ist auch im leben ein bisschen
schauspieler das gehört glaube ich dazu
mann mann beobachtet vielen man ist auch
in der lage sich bisschen chamäleon
mäßig zu verstellen
aber ich bin eigentlich ein normaler
junge
ich sitze nicht in embryonale haltung in
meinem zimmer am wippen und saba und
spiele mit meinen fäkalien das ist er
nicht der fall
okay ich bin ein psychisch labiler
mensch ich bin aber auch nicht dabei
das stimmt ja das habe ich wohl auch
gehört dann bin ich vielleicht doch nur
ein halber schauspieler okay gut
zusammen genauso jetzt aber mal rot wir
machen das immer im wechsel ein auf und
ab sowie die musik
ich lasse es fallen
deine texte erinnern oft an den witz der
arzt bist du der farin urlaub für arme
der ärzte vergleich ist ja ist ja sehr
gehypt worden sage ich mal
die die diese dieser trend mich damit zu
vergleichen das hat irgendwann damit
angefangen dann kam es immer da kann man
sich dem nicht entziehen selbst in den
roten fragen hatte sich niedergeschlagen
ich selbst habe die ärzte allerdings nie
wirklich bewusst gehört deswegen könnte
ich jetzt auch nicht beurteilen ob ich
anfangen urlaub für arme bereiche für
mittelständer bin ich ich bin ich und
dennoch allerdings natürlich keine front
gegen die ärzte ich glaube also was ich
von den kennedy songs die man kennt sind
natürlich cool
dann könnte das höchstwahrscheinlich
deswegen das ist auch ein punkt
vielleicht deswegen sehr viele gangster
rap um zu vermeiden dass musiker die in
ähnlichen ansatz haben dass ich mich
dann ärgern könnte ärgern könnte darüber
dass die vielleicht mehr ideen
vorweggenommen haben dass die dass die
etwas wegnehmen ja okay gut verstanden
nächste frage der grünen
und weg damit textlich findest du dich
weit über echtem trailerpark niveau wie
schreibt man so clevere lyrics das
müsste doch eigentlich ne rote frage
sein wenn man noch einen seitenhieb
gegeben aber du willst ja im grünen
gebaut ja ich aber ich bin ja auch teil
der band und der scheiße wenn die band
beleidigt wird dann fühle ich mich
natürlich auch schwer getroffen
die rot grün war vielleicht ist das hier
ab hier rot und hier wäre wäre grün ja
das ist natürlich erstmal eine eine eine
farce trailerpark als niveaulos zu
bezeichnen
ja es ist sehr viel gedanken müll der
überall abgelagert wird aber das ist ja
auch geil und das konzept der sache
das heißt natürlich nicht dass meine
kollegen nicht in der lage wären
kleinere lyrik zu schreiben das ich
finde das ja weit hergeholt und wie
schreibt man so clevere lyrics ja mit
mit dem stift der einem zur verfügung
steht auf die weißen leinwand wenn man
die familie gericht hat auf die weiße
leinwand kinder nachweislich wenn das
weiße licht da ist wenn man all der
gedanken müll abgeladen ist dabei
trailerpark die die müllhalde ist
gefüllt und man man schreibt seine
lyrics auf sehr gut
so was soll denn jetzt erst die rote
frage geben
noch schlimmer ich mal gespannt
backstreet boys 2 1 gehts wieder mit
trailer park weiter ich habe es nämlich
gerade befindet sich auf dem index
bist du eine gefährdung für die jugend
ja wahrscheinlich schon aber ich denke
mal dass gefährdung für die jugend ist
ja eine frage von welchem standpunkt man
das aussehen würde ein elternteil wird
dies als gefährdung erkennen können wird
wenn es ein guter elternteil ist sagen
halt stopp ich schiebe hier die grenze
davor und dann hatte auch sein
ein teil als als vater als mutter gut
ausgeführt so wie sich das gehört
ich selbst bin eine gefährdung für
niemanden laut vertrag ist eine
gefährdung für niemanden wir sind
künstler wir sind musiker wir sind
kabarettisten wir machen
spaßige rap musik und und schicken das
in den äther und wer das als gefährdung
sieht muss sich davor schützen
ok mit dem schutzschild
wie kommt s russen kommen wenn du bist
ja ein künstler gesagt ich empfinde die
verantwortung da hat er irgendwie
niemand
das scheint nicht so verantwortlich zu
sein da offensichtlich hat da
irgendjemand hatte hat sich da
eingeschlichen oder wieder in die in die
fragen kiste ins fragen lotto ja ich
sehe die verantwortung natürlich in
erster linie wie die meisten künstler
bei den menschen die davon betroffen
sind
da ich da ich eine beschneidung der
kunst natürlich nicht zustimmen das ist
ja klar dass als künstler ist man gegen
zensur und ist man dafür dass seine
musik in allen
allen formen und farben stattfinden kann
und dass dafür wird man auch immer
einstehen als künstler noch cds von
anderen künstler die auf dem index
stehen
teilweise ist ja durchaus berechtigt
hinter dem titel auf der wii nix stehen
weil sie einfach gewalt verherrlichen
und ungefiltert und ja wenn das bei
einer nazi bayern passiert dann ist es
natürlich auch gut und richtig und dass
das ist ja das ist ja auch okay das ist
ja auch eine andere liste es gibt am
index liste a und b glaube ich oder so
heißt also aber es gibt halt diese
dieser andere natürlich hofft er also
nicht auf der ganz bösen bösen ich weiß
auch nicht fertig auf jeden fall sollte
halt jede mit normalem verstand klar
sein dass unsere musik eine satire ist
und dass das humorvoll mit sachen
spielen ich bin da nicht verstanden
waren
wir sind definitiv missverstanden worden
wir sind nicht gefühl nicht genug
gefragt worden wir wurden über
überrumpelt wir sind wer wir sind da
einfach eingestampft worden von einer
von einer schutz behörde die nicht
richtig hinhören möchte und die nicht
richtig die nicht richtig differenzieren
kann scheinbar ok verlieren in dem thema
genau da müssen wir jetzt ja auch die
jugend schriften anrufen
stimmt das oder sich das dann hätten wir
die auch in einer reihe meinung stehen
gemeinsam mit denen unseren tisch setzen
und nochmal fremden zu reden
ja ja wir waren da ja auch das haben wir
auch ein bisschen geredet aber dann
wurden wir auch dann wieder raus gebeten
und
nicht gereicht ja ich nehme noch mal
eine rote frage damit ich mit einer
grünen aufhören kann denn ich das gern
ein dass ein freund des events ebenso
ebenso du programm erst einmal kommerz
schweine somit meine erzfeinde meine
band schönes lied hast du dich bei
deinem momentanen erfolg nicht selbst
ausverkauft das ist nämlich das ist
nämlich die sache der song der zitiert
wird heißt meine band und er wird
natürlich jetzt hin und wieder immer mal
zu rate gezogen
ich habe mich verändert ich mache ganz
andere musik jetzt das klingt auf einmal
ganz anders auf einmal klingelt klingt
es etwas poppig und melodiös und
eingängig und das gefällt natürlich
nicht den leuten die das die das von
anfang an gehört haben sie werfen einen
kommerz vor und und dass man sich
verändert hat aufgrund einer eine einem
ziel wie hier verdacht
der verdacht liegt immer noch das ist
das ist klar aber man guckt sich dann
die musik nicht an denn die musik wäre
die musik auf kommerz auf ausgelegt dann
hätte ich den song willst du mit drogen
nehmen über ein anderes thema mit
derselben musik geschrieben
dann wäre das auch radiotauglich gewesen
und hatte überall gespielt werden können
ich möchte die die dinge die in meinem
kopf sind in musik packen und das
verständnis davon wie diese musik klingt
wie diese musik klingen soll die ich da
mache
das wandelt sich ja weil ich mich als
mensch wandeln wenn ich älter werde weil
ich weil ich andere geschmäcker manchmal
bekomme weil ich manchmal er lust habe
was das gesangliches zu machen etwas
melodiöses mit gitarren zu machen und
deswegen hat man manchmal dann einfach
die lust das raus zu lassen und jetzt
die songs so anzugehen und es jetzt so
zu machen
mein sohn meine band hat es im prinzip
diese entwicklung vorhergesagt schon
damals ich habe
ich habe genau dieses thema behandelt
aus der sicht eines fans geschrieben der
seine band für sich beansprucht die
besitzansprüche hat dass diese band sich
nicht verändern daher möchte seine band
am liebsten in seinem keller einsperren
dass sie für keinen anderen musizieren
außer für ihn und immer dasselbe machen
sich nie verändern dürfen und jeder der
nun ernsthaft diesen song zu rate zieht
entlarvt sich im prinzip selbst als als
fanatischer ewig gestriger ich denke
schon dass ist das geht hin und wieder
wird es dann mal so noch mal in
erinnerung gerufen
dieses lied ich hoffe es gerne auch
selbst in erinnerung
aber es ist wie alle meine lieder ist
steht da steht im raum und man kann
jetzt machen daraus muss man heute das
nicht oft auch das problem dass die
zuhörer ich damals sarkasmus ironie und
so weiter gar nicht aus hören oder auch
der dazu nicht mehr sagen willst du dich
nicht ich habe ab und zu missverstanden
und dann kommt wieder der krieg dazu
denn dann gibt es die leute die den
sarkasmus und die iren verstehen und
gibt es die leute die sie nicht
verstehen und dann heißt es wieder du
hast es ja gar nicht verstanden und ich
verstehe es viel besser als du und
deswegen dieser streit entschädigt mich
schon wieder dafür dass das manche leute
vielleicht nicht verstehen und dieser
streit an sich kann ja auch wieder
sachen anregen
das ist ja du freust dich darüber die
intensive diskussion ich freue mich
immer über diskussion
genau das ist ja das was man als
künstler ist jemand der einen
dominostein an schubst und irgendwelche
kettenreaktion auslöst die man
vielleicht gar nicht mal ab sehen kann
ok wechsel pfarrer em jawohl ich freue
mich schon das bestimmt wieder irgendein
kleiner seitenhieb greifen oh nein wie
konnte er sich nur einschleichen
dube dienst dich beim battle rap
verpasst aber alles zumeist mit einer
per mit einer gehörigen prise humor und
satire wie wird man so vielseitig da ist
nun battle rap geschrieben es ist humor
und satire beschrieben
das sind zwei seiten viel vielseitig 22
seiten sind da noch gar nicht mal so
vielseitig also das ist ja das ist ja
noch gar nicht so viel gefehlt da ist
das schon viel
naja ich bin habe battle rap gehört habe
habe ich dir erzählt gangsta rap rauf
und runter und ich bin aber auch wie
auch bereits schon jetzt in unserem
gespräch erwähnt ein humorvoller
lustiger mensch und ein fan von von
guter guter comedy guten gute novizin na
und dass das ist ja dann liegt ja schon
alles auf dem tisch was man zusammen
basteln kann was man in den topf werfen
kann und was neues ausprobiert ich werde
sehr viel probieren es wird viel
gebastelt
okay sie sind gespannt ich erst vielen
dank ich bin eben so